round 2 of the London chess classic the
last stop on the grand chest tour after
a first day of unusual mistakes the
players came into the round looking to
show why they're the best chess players
in the world former world champion vishy
anand quickly built up a nice advantage
against my team vashi lagrave and in the
end the tiger from Madras managed to
finish off the game with a sharp tactic
to keep himself in striking distance of
first place u.s. and Olympic champion
fabiano caruana seemed to be in dire
straits against the Bulgarian Vasily
topalov but with some tenacious defense
the American turned the tables to join
three others in a tie for second but the
hero of the round was grandchester a
leader Wesley so who ground down
Britain's Michael Adams to claim the
sole lead in the event as well as become
one of only a dozen players in history
to break the mythic 2800 barrier will
history continue to be made at an event
that has become a true classic on the
tour round reaction live from London
starts right now